major
story speaking of transgenderism
speaking of these
pulling on your heartstrings sort of
social issues made your story out of
ukraine
not the shelling of civilians in kiev
not the
fight of the ukrainian people to stop
russian aggression no no the story that
business insider decided to focus on
how a transgender ukrainian man escaped
russia's invasion
he he quote unquote says i painted my
nails violet and wore mom's shirt to
look more girly
so that's how he now the transgender
ukrainian man escaped the invasion and i
first start reading that headline you
read it kind of quickly you say hold on
why is a a man escaping the invasion
the way that it works in ukraine right
now
is that women and girls are allowed to
leave
women and children are allowed to leave
but the men have to stay in ukraine
because the men are expected to fight
for their country against russian
aggression
this is the right thing to do and it
happens to be the policy in ukraine so
why is a man escaping
the war why isn't he fighting oh right
because he's not a man because when they
say transgender man they mean a woman
who is pretending to be a man
either because she's confused and
believes because of some fantasy that
she is actually a man or because she
just really wants to be a man and she
isn't one but she wants to pretend
either way
she's being allowed to leave because
she's a man
or because she's a woman rather and not
actually a man now she says she painted
her nails violet and wore mom's shirt to
look more girly she doesn't need to do
very much to look more girly she's a
girl
but what what is so striking about this
issue
and it just
drives home everything we have said
about the transgender craze
is
we are told that transgender men are men
transgender women are women there's no
distinction between a transgender man
and a man or a transgender woman and a
woman i don't know why we have that
extra adjective there beforehand because
there's no difference whatsoever they
just gave richard levine who is the
undersecretary of health he's a man who
believes that he's a woman is the
assistant secretary of health in america
shows you the state of our country he
just won an award from some organization
to name him one of the women of the year
because he's a woman you go girl you get
it right
so this woman is a man
until it's inconvenient to be a man
this woman is a man until
she
pretending to be he is asked to fight
for her country to do one of the duties
of being a man and then all of a sudden
let's paint my nails and go to a slumber
party because i'm a girl let's go get
some chardonnay on the weekend and she
she flees the country
this is a problem with the transgender
movement more broadly
and
really it's a problem with our society
at the broadest level
we all want the privileges
that other people have
we never want the duties that other
people have
we always we want to be able to do
whatever we want whenever we want to do
it
we that is our view of liberation and
transgenderism at its core is a radical
liberation movement just like all
movements from the left are radical
liberation movements
not just liberation from governments
that's how they began not just
liberation from social convention that's
how it continued but liberation from
nature and biology itself so it's this
radical liberation movement we believe
to be truly free you need to be able to
do whatever you want to do in our
culture
but this liberation never involves
taking on responsibilities
taking on duty this is i think this is
probably the biggest distinction between
the leftist and liberal view of the
world and the conservative view of the
world
the liberal and leftist view of the
world
looks at the world primarily from
perspective of rights
and entitlement
and on the more radical left end it's
entitlement two things positive rights
my entitlement two
enter into the women's bathroom if i'm
really a man my entitlement two some
health care service my entitlement two
your money and your labor and on the
more modest side of it it's my
entitlement
my right
from aggression my right to life liberty
and property the negative rights right
it's all these rights rights righteous
rights but on the conservative side we
look and we say no no i'm not born
primarily with rights
i am born primarily with duty and
obligations i'm born into a family of a
little baby boy i'm born into a family
i have obligations to my family and to
my community and to my country if you
view the world that way then you're
going to stay and fight for your country
but if you adopt crazy ideologies
radical leftist ideologies like
transgenderism you're never going to
look at the world like that and so it's
no surprise
that this transgender man also known as
a confused woman
is fleeing at the first sign of trouble
not so fun to be a man when the bullets
are flying is it right now head on over
to priceline.com since 1998 priceline
has been the best way for travelers to
book the trip that they want at the
price they can afford priceline saves
consumers more than 1 billion dollars
every year billion with a b so that
their customers never have to miss the
moments that matter with priceline you
can save up to 60 on your favorite
hotels you can also get exclusive deals
on rental cars and flights when you save
more you can do more get more wow this
view is incredible more
another round of room service please
more booyah i'm extending my vacation
sorry boss sorry ben
there are a few things that feel as good
as knowing you saved money with the
discounts priceline offers you get that
feeling a lot because when you save more
you can enjoy more you can do more at
priceline every trip is a big deal
priceline knows that every trip is a big
deal so when you're ready to book the
next one check out priceline.com for the
easiest way to get more wow more more
booyah just to name a few things
out of it
i'm glad you like that clip now i need
you to ring the bell please
you'll get the notifications you'll
subscribe and then also head on over to
apple podcast spotify stitcher google
play wherever you get your audio podcast
subscribe to the michael knowles show
m-i-c-h-a-e-l space canon w-l-e-s space
s-h-o-w
subscribe right now you will get all of
our latest episodes we'll see you next
time
[Music]
[Music]
you